4 la suisse 4 6
[Musique]
cyril kamar au thème tous les jours j'ai
tout enlevé à une série d'écoutés
les premiers thèmes l'évolution des
fruits secs du moyen-âge 12e les
vainqueurs de roland garros demi là je
crois qu'on a un spécialiste ce n'est
pas terminé troisième thème les enfants
cachés de benjamin castaldi à travers le
monde il que quelqu'un me dit alors il
je sais pas si c'est de pas dit plus que
le quatrième tél et les chiffres entre 1
et 3 là je vais prendre je prends des
risques
vous savez je suis un passionné de
prayssac puisque je travaillais pour
noix de cajou point fr comment des
années et je vais prendre les vainqueurs
de roland garros b92
attention c'est le parti mme anne
marcotte je rappelle le principe
toujours appel au principe avec plaisir
je dois répondre à chaque fois et mettre
le le petit suisse dans la bouche
attention c'est parti à khartoum appelle
le thème des vainqueurs de roland garros
de 80 à 2000 première questionner ya pas
y'a pas que mediapart gros chrono on ya
pas qu on n'a pas un habillage fois les
mois en régie avait tiré les oreilles
excusez moi c'est cela qui vous parle
oui je vois la vie et un chrono
également à lewis est la mienne un
chrono le chrono harry des klaxons ou
nathan mais j'en ai même topo l'émission
je suis de passage merci merci on se
rappelle le milieu de semaine prochaine
merci attention série subway est qu est
le seul joueur français à avoir remporté
le tour de roland garros
yannick noah qu'est les nationalités de
yevgeny kafelnikov vainqueur de roland
garros en 96 97 et 2002
quel âge avait michael chang sa victoire
au langage michael chang victoire de
roland garros cage avec celle de 14-18
ans et 3 mois non non 17 ans je ne le
fais pas quel jour a remporté le tournoi
de roland garros en 2004
[Musique]
mais en 2004 c'est pas que juste avant
curpen non c'est gaudio quel joueur est
le seul à avoir emporté cinq fois de
suite le ton de roland garros
c'est là le 5 watt 8 c borg nadal à
nadal le maire de kehl ville a valu
andre agassi son nombre de cas de la
vega bonnes réponses
en quelle année
ok avec carlos moya remporté le tournoi
de roland garros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette dernière
ouais ouais quelle est la nationalité du
vainqueur 2010 set du tournoi lors de
roland garros nationalité du vainqueur
mais 2017
nous allons jouer 2007 allant de la
charité une question pour piquer son
pour kelly proulx quel joueur bas henri
leconte en 88 en finale de roland garros
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le